[MUSIC PLAYING]
ARIA DEAN: Hi.
ALICE HONG: Hello.
CYNTHIA HUA: Hi
Hi.
BEN CULLEN WILLIAMS: Hi.
ROHINI DEVASHER: Good, good.
How are you?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FARID RAKUN: I'm in Jakarta.
ROHINI DEVASHER: I'm
based in Noida in India.
STEPHEN TAYO: In Lagos, Nigeria.
MATTHEW GROH: Cambridge,
Massachusetts.
SUMAYYA VALLY: Johannesburg
in South Africa.
MARTIAL GEOFFRE ROULAND:
South of France.
RISA PUNO: New York City.
ADAM HAAR HOROWITZ:
Mendocino County, I'm
in northern California.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ZACH LIEBERMAN: One thing
that makes Open Lab unique,
is that it's really
driven by artwork first.
FREYA MURRAY: And it was about
supporting and facilitating
experimentation.
ZACH LIEBERMAN: And
the general premise
is to pair artists
and technologists
to work on a project for 48
hours and see what happens.
FREYA MURRAY: In a
time where it's not
possible to meet
physically, how we
could recreate the feeling
of a lab in virtual space.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Everyone,
it's so exciting to be here.
PATTIE MAES: So the Media Lab
is unique among research labs
in the world, in that we
have always recognized
the value of bringing together
different modes of thinking
and creative work.
DOUGLAS ECK: It's also
incredibly important
to find times for sprints
like this, where we're
trying to express ourselves.
GAEL HUGO: I'm really happy
to see like ideas coming up
and see where it can go.
HANNAH ANDREWS: And we're
super excited see what
happens in the next few days.
ANI LIU: What we're
trying to build
is something that
can create music,
depending on your mood
or emotional state.
NICK RYAN: If one was to collect
sound from an entire continent,
could you actually zoom
out from it and hear it?
MATTHEW BURROWS: The
idea of an economy that
is a kind of horizontal
economy, pushes money
across the community.
ARIA DEAN: Yeah,
automated camera system
for performance and film
that can live broadcast.
NICOLAS AYOUB: How
can we give people
a better experience of the
physical in a virtual way?
STEPHEN TAYO: For example,
how can we protest virtually?
BEN CULLEN WILLIAMS: Right
now, we're working on a project
to explore grief and
loss in a digital space.
KRYSTIE WRIGHT: Creating empathy
through connection to nature.
ROHINI DEVASHER: I'm also
interested in those stories
where people talk
about why the sun is
the most important
object to them
or why a solar
eclipse completely
changed this man's life.
SUMAYYA VALLY: Passing
on sound and about
experiencing a
place through sound.
FARID RAKUN: An online
platform where we
can record our dreams together.
RYAN MILLER: Whether
or not that's
a football club that you
go to or I don't know,
a bowling club or whatever,
nightclubs are no different,
and we want to be able to
provide a space for people
to like meet
like-minded individuals
and still build relationships.
RISA PUNO: I think
we're trying to solve,
like make it easy for people
to express how they are
and understand how they are.
XIN LIU: Our live
streaming service
caught living sounds,
which were made
during for the
time of quarantine
to connect people
with nature sounds.
LONI LANDAN: We miss this
audience-performer interaction.
And that's how we
got to applause.
And maybe through applause, we
can feel some kind of feedback.
ZACH LIEBERMAN: I
was so excited to see
what happens in 48 hours.
But you know, the
next thing for me
is what happens in two
weeks, what happens
in two months and two years.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
RACHAEL PAZNAN: It's
rare and really special
to be able to be paired
with technologists.
It's something I've never
had that opportunity before.
I don't think Loni's ever
ADAM HAAR HOROWITZ: The
world seems especially
starved for beauty
right now, and it
seems like our only answer
in the coming months
is going to be
something digital.
LONI LANDAN: And I
think the bigger picture
here with the
collaboration, is to ask
these important questions
of how does COVID-19
and how does this
quarantine affect
so many different issues.
ROHINI DEVASHER:
Thank you very much.
AISHNI PARAB: Take care.
STEPHEN TAYO: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]